hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to this is
a story about an old man who has lost
all hope in life all because of his
misguided faith in a single engine
however with the help of his
granddaughter and the courage of a small
town he may be able to find that special
magic to make his engine run
Academy Award nominee Peter Fonda
Academy Award nominee Alec Baldwin most
adorable smile award mara Wilson really
that annoying mrs. Doubtfire kid um okay
Thomas the Tank Engine
okay this joke is this come on come on
where's the real summary come on there
is no way that promised the Tank Engine
is Anna Peter Fonda and Alec Baldwin
movie I'm right Peter Fonda and Alec
Baldwin are in a Thomas the Tank Engine
movie what trust me most of America was
as shocked as you are what the hell are
these two big dramatic actors doing in
something as brainless as Thomas the
Tank Engine I mean it's not that it's a
kid's film he'll a Disney movie or a
Pixar movie or something of substance
would make more sense but it's Thomas
the fucking tank engine the show PBS
Plus on whatever the dog is too
intimidating what does it all come
together let's take a look meet Thomas
he's our number-one hero
so immediately you're hoping mr. Roger's
trolley comes in and kicks the oiled
asses out of these characters but
unfortunately we're not so lucky
we do however see our first problem with
this film seven
hey so do we appreciate practicing your
numbers Gordon I'm counting how many
seconds later you are the mouse dog mo
hey fuckin crappy I'm just a understand
on the show cuz it looks like they have
a budget that makes Gumby look like
studio ghibli but come on it can't be
your father in this don't what Peter
Fonda to think you're this goddamn lazy
do you you gotta know facial expressions
in your library but you can't come up
with one motor to go inside the
characters lips to make it move up and
down come on I can do better watch say
golden I was just wondering why we live
in a town called Sodor it's at a
retirement home
Lord of the Ring villain I'm just trying
to put together how we procreate I mean
do trains have sperm goodness gracious
me but somehow still like creepy the way
you're doing
so we're introduced to a place called
shining time where the humans are just
as lifeless as the trains they even have
their own obnoxiously fat
profanity-laced Tinkerbell played by
Alec Baldwin who's going to sing to us
about the town your shiny
I think true stars do your own cobbler
super generic song it sounds like
hundreds of other song
finger always liked in the song that's
why no one remembers is generic some
generic song some jackass wrote this in
his sleep
generic song generic song it shuts up
your kids so you can't come
[Music]
and by the way I think that you're going
to help me and Thomas somewhere in this
story um okay
are you gonna fill us in on that at all
that's kind of a lot of pressure to
throw on a little kid and then suddenly
not go in any detail how would you like
it if barny the dinosaur in the middle
of the song said some shits going down
be ready for it
we're a happy family so I guess they
find out a bad train named diesel has
come to town for no other reason than to
cause trouble I've come back to find a
lost Stephen what I'm gonna destroy her
and dominate you whoa keep it a bedroom
diesel I'm tired of being the bottom
bitch just for one I want to be in
control of my trains but we were just
talking about that Detroit has been my
life they're what
hey jobs finished I reckon shining time
is the best welcome side of any town in
our Valley what's up well I'm glad you
agree Wow kid you got to start seeing
some girls you heard that train whistle
sooner than it hears itself well all
that excitement gets him working his way
up to muffle Mountain or Peter Fonda
played the owner of a Tank Engine he's
named Lady whom we heard about earlier
long ago I made a mistake his ladies
caretaker an evil diesel found lady and
threatened to destroy her he chased her
used up all her coal then he crashed her
tried my best to fix her up
but I've never been able to make up for
the mistake
okay Peter I'm just going to tell you
right now you're trying way too hard
here
this isn't you'll read gold it's Thomas
the fucking Tank Engine I don't usually
say this but you don't understand if you
don't put your all into it I mean why
can't you be more like it is a very
important
well maybe not like this yes if Peter
Fonda is too miserable in this movie
then Alec Baldwin is far too happy he
plays mr. conductor think Bob's the
builders lobotomized grandpa and you'll
have a pretty good idea what he's like
Stacey what did you find this painting
no haka uh-uh
no ladies the proper responses ah David
David ah this place looks like the
Island of Sodor but how would Burnett
stone travel there without Goldust
I guess he travels back and forth
between shining time and Sodor and
that's why people aren't basing
themselves with terror whenever he rides
but what's so weird about it is that
there's nothing really magical about
Sodor except for the fact that the
trains talk wouldn't it make more sense
just to have it all take place in one
world why not just have a world where
trains talk and that's it why is the
real world in it at all hey would you
like to go to the magical land of
corridors I sure would
just like the real world what's so
magical about it
well that mask over there can smell
garlic chicken spring rolls
sure
this isn't really magical like Stacey
much sense danger he didn't want either
brillier me to leave shining time oh
yeah it looks really distressed there I
have to concentrate now muck goodbyes
not perfect
sparkle Sparkle Sparkle I know you're
thinking to yourself how could any
successful actor bring himself to star
in a movie that requires him to say the
line sparkle Sparkle Sparkle well I
think you underestimate the power of
those words
I think Baldwin saw the possibilities of
that line the magic it possesses and the
ability to touch an entire generation
don't act like these words haven't had a
huge impact on your life
hey Farkle Farkle Farkle fuck yes
sparkle Sparkle Sparkle
oh yeah you're okay yeah meanwhile we
see father continuing to mope get
yesterday's phones there's a lot of it
maybe two sparkles
one day one of his family returned what
do you tell that to guard their well
young brunette I didn't charge you well
yeah say quite and all its services
fucking Trant engine trouble me that
deserves it
let's free trip to Yuma or the limey
Ghost Rider deserves more energy than
that I just don't seem to understand
about
Oh matches it okay we're going to break
while I get so when to clearly show him
how not to give a shit in a performance
yes yes give me the girl from the remake
of Miracle on 34th Street by the way Sam
sparkle Sparkle Sparkle walk yeah
here we go Fonda this is the proper
performance to give in this movie mara
Wilson clearly going through puberty
clearly at the age where she's
embarrassed to be seen in this piece of
crap and clearly just doing this to pay
off her future student loss watch this
performance and tell me if at any moment
she looks invested Santa's been so sad
since grandma Tasha died did you get it
here I'm making him a friendship
bracelet awkward expression honey that's
good
don't know how we're where to look and
I'd rather just stay here with you no
commitment whatsoever can you give the
same uncomfortable hug you'd give a
Chucky Cheese animatronic I'm gonna go
up this way okay and lead the actors you
obviously just met today you see father
that's that's what we're expecting more
from the master she clearly doesn't give
a crap so we find out a little bit more
about that lady engine and why diesel
wants to destroy her so much diesel
knows that the lost engine in the legend
really exists what legend of an engine
whose magic makes her more powerful than
diesel will ever be that's why he wants
to find her by the way you notice
something seriously lacking in Thomas
the tankard yeah Thomas the Tank Engine
he's barely in this he shows up smile
and then we cut to either over acting
under acting or good god it's Thomas
that fucking Tank Engine acting oh well
maybe Baldwin can bring some balance
back to this flick as he stands here
completely alone and yet talks to him so
so who dropped the ball I'd like to have
a nice cup of hot cocoa would you fellas
care to join me no what would you rather
do instead go outside and play well I
can understand that what do you think
why do you keep hitting him like that
they're gonna have to have a timeout Oh
30 rock please give him a career I'm
sure he'll gladly sacrifice a thin
physique and black hair if you only give
him the hit shows what diesel arrives at
Baldwin discovers he suddenly can't use
his Sparkle Sparkle Sparkle
you losing your sparkle huh all we can
do is hold our blow Chelle faces what is
that that's right it should the diesel
and if I throw this in your tank it will
seize you up for good
wait so sugar is the big kryptonite in
this world well why doesn't he just hear
me a packet of Splendor around all the
time though nor help if the magic dust
is so magical can you just bring a
normal-sized person into the world
there'll be a giant fair so where's that
people big family never really told me
what to do when a gold dust crisis they
only said if you can't remember the clue
the windmill will remind you but where
is the windmill so he tries to figure
out his Sparkle impotency but thankfully
hope comes in the form of Haley Joel
Osment in a wig I don't suppose you know
well track freeze do you is it that one
oh why not the hell could go wrong just
getting on a train that could go
anywhere that I was advised by a dog
divorce it's not like it could lead to
another crazy Alec Baldwin breakdown I
notice you left your thinking cap behind
try these instead they're good for the
brave
plain drain mountain fountain that might
be something I think I'll try the celery
no you need to try the antipsychotics
honey
sausage bicycle toothpaste beach beach
beach okay I have no idea what that
scene was about I am now totally
convinced the Alan Ball that one nut and
they just shot a movie around hell maybe
it was supposed to be about a
grandfather his granddaughter and a
train but Baldwin just started shouting
gold Dustin Sparkle Sparkle Sparkle then
they had to make a kids movie out of it
this is family starting to make sense
now he's talking to flowers you know
good him does well another breakdown is
totally understandable but not always
acceptable just look at how he reacted
when Percy came in late I'm gonna let
you know just how disappointed in you I
am and how angry I am with you that
you've done this to me again
Tory would promise little pig and I'm
gonna straighten your ass out don't
default mr. conductor Samarra comes
across mr. conductors son named jr. and
an answer to your question I have no
idea why he's Scottish but really if
that's the biggest concern in this movie
you're in a good place
yeah do you I'm Lilly for you are you
doing yeah I'm totally stone so none of
this surprises me see you early
well that was pointless so she's picked
up and driven to her grandpa's place
where they form an immediate connection
by him poking the fireplace and her
going straight to sleep it's the human
bonding that makes this film work folks
but diesel finds mr. conductor and
threatens to throw him off a bridge
[Music]
nah
Hey
seven
[Music]
normally I'd say that by accident but
it's Alec Baldwin
he knew what he was doing did you put
all this here for me but you must have
known that I was coming how kind of you
am I
Alec Baldwin's delusion this is all Alec
Baldwin's delusion if it might matter is
this so cold help the audience was
supposed to give that was mentioned
earlier come on even Care Bears was more
interactive than that
Bailey's asked you to do something any
movie can just show something being done
and claim that you did that you did that
you you did that you did that you shame
this must be the clue to unlock the
source of the gold dust Stoke up the
magic in the mountains and the lady will
smile are you sure that's not toke up
the magic because I think a lot of that
was going on while this movie was made
good morning mr. stone I'm writing in
the shining time could really film with
me if she'd like to I'd like to yeah by
the way something else to keep in mind
in this movie is that Mara Wilson never
keeps her lip closed if things out like
in every single scene I'd like to
[Music]
she can go well lady what are we to do
it all seems so much easier when Tasha
and I were children fucking die dad dad
every turn you appear on screen you make
me wanna sweat my wrist
don't ever host a birthday party come on
kids let's go hit the pinata the pinata
is dead and you'll kill him
but Laura comes across junior again as
she convinces him to take her within to
Sodor
can we be back here by sunset hope so
yeah probably chill wait for them to
meet at this moment as opposed to
earlier just with the same time so he
shrinks her down to his size and you'll
never guess who they come across Thomas
yeah remember he's in this dancing too
he goes ahead and takes them to mr.
conductor who's still trying to figure
out the clue he was given wait are they
father and son or cousins he called him
junior yet he's constantly saying cuz
Junior I want you to listen to me and I
want you to listen to me very carefully
this is just cousin maybe their fault if
the Mario Brothers can be father and son
anything's fucking possible so they
figure out they can't travel through
worlds without gold dust but somehow
trains can still travel okay but there's
some kind of magic that makes lady work
but they don't know what it is but it
might have something to do with this
coal that they found in the tunnel way
in between worlds with will allow that
you to make gold does as she rides and
when did this plot becomes a kids
version of momento yeah it gets really
needlessly complicated especially for a
film that's meant to be so simple but I
guess the coal they find does get lady
working and they ride her off again
well my lady and the lights are all
green for you now okay some Prozac let
me come across the evil diesel and they
have to outrun him
ah stop you just open up and realize the
movie he was in she's part of the clue
to the source of the gold now I'll get
him for that stone no you won't because
the magic you refuse to believe in will
get the better of you you know what go
back to being depressed I think I like
it ran away but they come across an
unstable bridge where decal me to that
prepare to meet Amtrak and how so he say
buy a boat but they do figure out that
the shavings from Lady mixed with water
from the well makes gold does lipid IVA
pity and so we've come to the end of our
story and it's time for all of us to go
home just like Thomas oh yeah there's a
comment in this room he wasn't there if
I almost forgot
I mean cheese between all the supplies
confusing stories needless celebrities
and horrible editing I can't remember
once I know I just witnessed this movie
is so bizarre in its existence why is it
here why did it need to be made why did
it have these people in it is it
supposed to increase viewership of the
show well I've never seen the show and I
don't think I ever will either it's an
odd film with creepy trains that look
soulless and the less I can remember
it's not bad I mean I can't think of one
good thing that there's movie Davis hey
sparkle Sparkle Sparkle oh yeah good
point
I'm in Dessau a critic I remember so far
donate or go ah gasps Sparkle Sparkle
sparkle Fargo Fargo this
every now and then there appears a sign
that points just round the bed to a
place you'll find covered in over magic
comes over
showing fuck yeah sparkle Sparkle
Sparkle pottery
because the magic you refused to believe
in will get the better of you